10200 contamination au coronavirus
contre 11000 la semaine dernière des
signes encourageants sur le continent
africain
nous avons commencé à inverser lentement
la courbe mais il est tôt très tôt pour
se prononcer nous avons affaire à un
virus très délicat qui se propage très
rapidement mais il est important de
reconnaître ces légère tendance qui sont
positives c'est un bon indicateur qui
suggère que nous faisons les bonnes
choses sur le continent une régression
que les spécialistes scrute
attentivement par crainte d'une rechute
liée aux grands rassemblements
en cause notamment le coup d'état du 18
août dernier à bamako qui continue de
rassembler dans les rues les opposants
au président déchu ib cas nous demandons
au pays de rester extrêmement vigilant
les rassemblements politiques comme au
mali ne met pas en confiance compte tenu
des vulnérabilités des pays du sahel
si la réouverture des frontières et les
rassemblements ne sont pas organisées
avec les mesures d'hygiène qui
s'imposent
on risque d'avoir une recrudescence du
nombre de cas en effet les indicateurs
restent au rouge dans trois pays le
maroc le rwanda et l'ouganda enregistre
une nette augmentation des cas positifs
le maroc est particulièrement touché
avec pas moins de mille nouveaux cas par
jour
une situation qui inquiète le roi
mohamed 6 en l'absence d'un respect
rigoureux et responsable des consignes
sanitaires le nombre de contaminations
et de décès ira crescendo
les hôpitaux ne sera alors plus en
mesure de faire face à la pandémie
une recrudescence qui pourrait aussi
fragiliser les finances de certains pays
notamment l'afrique du sud pays le plus
touché du continent
le produit intérieur brut sud africains
devraient reculé de 7,2 pour cent en
2020 selon l'onu l'économie sud
africaine devrait mettre pas moins de
cinq ans à se relever de la récession
annoncée cette année